[Music]
Samuel leads here and I'm with my good
friend Marcos de Maria absolutely
pauletta to be here it's so good to have
you here we meet up quite regularly and
the cool thing about you Marcus is
you're your trainer like me
and you're also in property yes but
you're killing it right now we've
cryptocurrencies cryptocurrencies and
have been new for ages like when people
were talking about Bitcoin and stuff
you'd been doing it for ages
yeah and I wanted to just pick your
brain a bit and ask you some questions
about it
because it's something that I get asked
about from time to time and I don't know
that much about our listeners going on
your webinar and talking to you I have
invested you've also done stuff yeah in
Bitcoin but why don't you start just
tell us a little bit about background on
who you are okay so obviously again we
just talked about there's actually about
people calling me certain things but
Marcus de Maria and I've been trading
for the last 17 years and mainly stocks
and shares and become very good at it
over the years and that is what stopped
me from going into Bitcoin earlier
because it was whenever anybody came up
to me and kind of said you know Sir
Marcus you know she would get into the
digital I know no do not do you know you
know it's it's it's way too dangerous
Allah and I think it was like the sixth
person when I suddenly said why am i
telling people not to invest in
something that I know nothing about you
know so yeah so so so I went deep down
back in 2016 I just did a real deep dive
research summer so then I wrote a book
about it at the end of it but but really
deep down to what it is and what I
thought I can't believe that I offer 17
years I should be one of the first
people to get in back when it was what
two years ago it was at a thousand two
years before that it was at a hundred
I'm a Bitcoin miner alone like I said
you've been in it doing this for years
because you also I think when I first
met you you're making really good money
in the stock market yes yes but now
you're on Bitcoin well I still do the
stock market yeah doing my
cost averaging 2016 was it when you
really a study Bitcoin and crypto keys
and then what happened yeah and so then
I started getting into it and just first
of all after I stopped washing myself
that I hadn't gotten in was like you
know you how you do you get him with a
little bit 5,000 and another 5,000 and
you know you stop building it up and by
the end of the year I'd accumulated 2017
800,000 either your own money you'd put
any me yeah so you put your own personal
money right so I grew it up so it's so
so so I put in maybe in the end I think
it was a hundred and forty thousand okay
cool and went up to eight hundred
thousand yeah that faster is it not like
gambling though a little bit is it's not
like like you know when you buy property
the property is never going to Sapir
worst case it might drop in price a
little bit or you might get bad tenant
you can always sell it do you not think
that teaching people and advising people
are encouraging people to invest into
something that could potentially just
disappear overnight
do not that's a bit risky because I know
you're very well respected you know
person trainer businessman what do you
say about no I John honestly I don't
agree with you III think that I don't
know whether you expected me to say that
but um is riskier there's no doubt about
it is riskier and you know we have our
property portfolio we have our stocks
and shares portfolio and then as I
always say you know five to ten percent
of your investments I've got to go into
something which has what I call
asymmetrical risk in other words you're
risking about five to ten percent but
you could be make I'm not kidding here I
really I'm not going you could be making
a thousand five thousand even ten
thousand percent one of my positions
went up fourteen thousand percent you
might have never ever seen anything like
that ever stop mark and that's seventeen
that's what you said on your webinar
yeah she's fantastic by the way I mean
if you haven't been on if you're
watching you've not been on Marcus's
crypto webinar it will blow your mind so
do it but on your webinar when you said
about how you know if you're invested in
property whatever that can be a very
safe investment but you should have I
think I tell me if I'm is quoted yeah
but you said something along the lines
of a small percentage of your of your
wealth should be on something that could
go crazy well that's what I believe yeah
I thought about I think that's good
advice I mean if you if you were support
100 percent of your net worth into
Bitcoin then maybe that would be a
there will be herb don't do it what no a
percent if you well for 95 percent of
your wealth into safe investments
property and different things like that
maybe business yes and then a small
purse that you offered to that coin that
then you've got everything to gain and
very very little to lose I would agree
with you that's actually you have to do
that yeah because that asymmetrical risk
is so important and it could be that
that might make you more money that year
then maybe some of the other stuff and
and and that's the whole point of this
kind of like you know don't you know
having that 5% so someone's watching
this right now and they're probably into
property because that this is a property
channel yeah and they're investing in
property maybe they've got one or two or
ten houses off property what advice
would you give to them would you say
that they need to really go away and do
some homework would you say they should
just set up an account and buy a couple
of bitcoins what you know I would never
say to anybody just get into anything
without doing some research first well
I'll tell you why I mean I have lots of
reasons but one of the reasons is is the
Bitcoin price and all the others are
theorem - list manera etc there's about
1,600 of them extremely volatile and
unless you know what you're doing you're
going to panic and you're gonna sell as
it comes down that is that is not a
thing to do we are near the beginning of
a massive bull market massive bull
market and so therefore what we need to
do is not do what everybody else is
doing and Samuel they're panicking they
are panicking panicking panicking
because the the price of Bitcoin went
from a thousand in one year when up to
20,000 and of course that's when
everybody got in yeah they wait they
wait till it goes up and they go look no
no okay now I'm gonna give him right and
this is like I think it's Warren Buffett
around when people are scared you should
be greedy would be kinda greedy you
should be scared
absolutely it's the same in in property
you know they wait for the market to be
really good and have it going great but
then when everything's bottomed out
they're scared when that's exactly when
you should be buying that's right now
people are being fearful and that's when
you need to be greedy
yeah and and I've added something on to
that you know not meaning to you know
serve the master but but but but then
what do you do what other people being
greedy that's one thing but what do you
do so when other people are being
fearful but what do you
do when you are being fearful as well
yeah you still have to buy yeah and
that's mindset in psychology which is
something we talk about a lot something
you talked about as well again on the
webinar and I'm gonna say this it's very
easy to go online and to see what every
man is dog is saying about Bitcoin and
crypto and spend you know weeks and
weeks and weeks research every noise
different but your webinar is just crazy
good thank you and that's what made me
want to pull you on this show because
you just summarized everything up and we
saw what you explained to me a little
bit about why you think bitcoin is gonna
go up what's going on with thee and
there's so much going on people don't
even realize this and there and even the
ones that like heard about they're
shrugging it off because they don't
understand it
ok I'll give you I'll give you one exact
is that the IC e the
IntercontinentalExchange yeah oh it's 23
different exchanges including the New
York Stock Exchange being business just
announced that they have been working
secretly without telling anybody
together with Microsoft together with
Boston Consulting Group and Starbucks
that they are going to launch a crypto
platform in November of this year now
what that means is that they are going
to allow the masses to start using
crypto currencies which means that your
Starbucks has 50 million customers and
they are going to be looking into
accepting via a little card you could
use a Visa card you can use mascot by
the way they are also mascot bees are
also building up their own blockchain as
well that's they've already declare that
and you can be pay using crypto
currencies as of the end of this year
that is a huge announcement it's gonna
go mainstream as a result that's just
one yeah and you that wasn't the one I
was actually you shedload Syria for them
okay so tell me a little bit about your
students and some of the successes they
have inked or some of the interesting
things they're doing cuz I know you've
made many people very wealthy yeah yeah
yes so so basically I mean people are
just basically I always say you know do
your own research but they kind of they
kind of they want to know what am i
doing and
what I do on my webinars you know have
webinars every two weeks and I basically
show them my account and then I show
them the ones that I have been getting
into so the cryptocurrencies that I've
been getting into also the icos the
initial coin offerings I've been getting
into and any public companies that are
on the stock exchange that are going to
benefit from this so there's lots of
ways of making money you don't just have
to buy cryptocurrencies and they've been
getting into some you know we've had
people making thousands of percents
2,000 percents three thousands of
percents some people have set up their
own rigs so they're now actually mining
their own Bitcoin as well there's it's
crazy there's so many there's actually
four different ways of making money it's
not just one just just the buying part
look if somebody was starting right now
you know most people are they're getting
into Bitcoin they're getting into a
theory which is the second largest
they're getting into Ripple the third
largest they're getting into a light
coin they're getting into - they're
getting into Manero they're getting into
a by the way we have to say this is not
investment advice please do your
research beforehand this is this is
really important but I think all the
ones that I just know we're going to do
really well but it's not investment
advice but there's some other ones you
know those are the big ones so I also
say to people you know put 40% into the
big solid ones you know there's others
in the top 20 and then there's others in
the top 50 that are going to massively
surpass you know not surpassed Bitcoin
and market capitalization but surpassed
in terms of percentage price increase
yeah some of my students have been
getting into some icos and have made
ridiculously high amounts of money
whether they've sold or not because I I
tell people don't sell we're at the
beginning you know they made the money
but it's they're still in their account
yeah I mean I mean and the reason I
wanted you on this channel is because I
mean I say it's a proper teacher it's
actually not this channel is really a
financial freedom Channel excellent it's
a channel how people can use property or
other things as a vehicle to become
financially for April in when did you
become financially free and how did you
achieve it oh wow we're going way back
now we're financially free cuz um maybe
approximately not not that long ago
maybe 7 years ago or so yeah and he
quite a remarkable story as well yes so
back
around 99 I was actually sleeping on my
brother's floor I was a hundred thousand
pounds and bad debt I didn't have any
properties by the way at that stage bad
debt right because people say Oh a
hundred thousand I've got mortgages much
no no I didn't have any only another car
I didn't ever sleeping back though
and there was a bad time that was a bad
time and it was probably the lowest you
know kind of financial financial point
but you know why it was a blessing in
disguise I know it sounds crazy but when
you're in that much pain you wake up one
day and you just go enough is enough
you draw the line and you move forward
and I did whatever I did I did lots of
thing I didn't I didn't just go donk
donk
I did not something I went up down up
down I did network marketing for two
years just didn't work for me personally
I know people that are making a lot of
money on it
I think my expectations were people said
to me you'd do it in a year and I think
that's we like to swear on this channel
yeah BS
yeah because because I think it's you
know three to five years and I I was
told one year he's that was my
expectations so after one and a half
years I I stopped how had they said
three to five years I would have carried
on I would have done extremely well so
it's all about expectations as much as
anything else there's other people out
there that talk a lot of BS you know
yeah and you don't and that's why you
know I'm also here and I and I agreed to
be on on these kind of things and then
you know we did actually you know you
know what the turning point was really
apart from going to seminars I guess
Tony Robbins I know you meant a lot of
courses
yeah but the Tony Roberts one was might
was was the one where I I quit my job
yeah the next day I literally quit my
job because he just pumped me up
probably saying things I've heard before
but saying it in a way that maybe I
needed to hear right now and and I made
a decision you know and then yes I went
on a lot of courses I did a lot of
different things did business startups
in different countries what was the
vehicle that achieve financial freedom
for you stocks and shares stops and yeah
yeah because well I know when we first
met you were killing it and stocks and
sherea and you're still doing that so
what do you what are your predictions
then going back to Bitcoin in say five
years time I know you can't say for sure
but what are your predictions on how
kryptos might have changed the way that
we do money oh my goodness
it's just because I mean maybe some
people don't even know what what bitcoin
is or the blockchain is so so blockchain
is just a system for you and I to
transact but there's nobody in the
middle because of the mode we need
somebody to say that I sent you the
money because otherwise you're gonna I'm
gonna say did you receive the money and
you're gonna go no and I'm gonna go oh
no you know and nobody can you're gonna
say send it to me again and I'm gonna go
but I did so so there has to be somebody
normally it's centralized there's a bank
or a central bank in the way so we're
going to get that out the way and now we
have a decentralized system with
thousands of computers around the world
on this massive excel spreadsheet called
a ledger doesn't matter you know
whatever Excel spreadsheet saying that I
did send it to you and it can't be
proven but it also can't be hacked it's
and here's the word immutable it can't
be hacked which means that we don't need
all the banks and you know Satoshi
Nakamoto came up with this in 2007 right
because of the financial crisis he said
enough because the banks have been
they've been very naughty to us yeah
something very naughty there and so and
and it's just enough and people have had
enough yeah and so now if they call it a
kind of you don't need to have that
trusted person in the way because the
system is trusted and that's what the
blockchain is all about yeah and so what
it allows I gotta give you one example
but you know it could be actually I've
got so many examples I get I wish much
like so there's one of it there's a
company called V chain I'm heavily
invested in that and I'm encouraging my
people to do that as well is they
actually trust they can actually track
by the blockchain whether this baby
powder came from the factory where it is
on the lorry to the Depot to the shops
to the end user customer and the end
user customer can actually scan it and
say this is real baby powder because in
China I don't know whether you heard
about this 600 babies who bought baby
powder and it wasn't baby powder 600
babies were put into hospital I know I
know you have a baby right and also six
babies died not one you know that
shouldn't happen yeah you know so they
can trust trust or you know that you see
the trust the trust and they could scan
all this it's all on the blockchain it's
written on there nobody can change it
you can't change this once it's written
on the block
that's what people want they they don't
want this centralized thing where people
are manipulated they're inflating
deflating changing you know going into
your bank account in Cyprus and taking
20% just cuz you have a hundred thousand
they don't want stuff like that and I
think right now there's probably gonna
be two types of people listening one is
gonna be saying what on earth are you
talking about you know what was this in
which case get educated yes the second
type of person is going to be saying
yeah yeah I've heard this before I knows
which is great um let me ask you a
question I know I went on your webinar
and I have my mind blown and loved it
and it's helped me a lot all I'm going
to be putting a link on this YouTube
video below because who to your webinar
if that's okay yes thank you I'd
encourage people check it out and go
least go on the webinar and have an
understanding about investments and
money in Kryptos and where things are
going and where the economy is going
from that standpoint but I'd like to ask
you a question why should and that
doesn't really make much difference to
you it's a free webinar right yeah it's
for our identify so I assumed you
alright
why should people attend your your free
book right now ah it's not a feel very
strongly about this I I feel that the
information that I will be giving on
that webinar is going to be
life-changing in the sense that there is
this massive transfer of wealth massive
transfer away from the big boys to us
into our pockets yeah and I'm not
talking about thousand see I'm talking
about a lot more than that about tens
that's hundreds of thousands maybe even
millions for the right person and and
you don't need a lot of money you need
maybe I said to people investing maybe
you know 500 start with $500 something
like that really small amounts and this
asymmetrical risk is so incredibly
important the blockchain is going to
change the way we do any kind of
business including in property as well
you know because it's just you've got to
do your research it's not a lot it's
what it may be 90 minutes with
question-answer it might be two hours
people do ask other questions and are
you until right at the end I do not go
well yeah I mean I know people pay you
thousands of pounds to sit with you and
pick your brain so I think it's a
no-brainer so I'm going to put a link
underneath this video
so check it out and get on to his free
webinar final words of advice maybe
around mindset or something because I
know you're a big believer in mindset
Tony Robbins fast
what would you say final piece of advice
to investors just to give them a bit of
encouragement inspiration in their
journey what would you say well I would
say that you can definitely do it I know
because I was on my brothers floor and
if I can do it you can do it as well and
you know I have seen so many of my
students who just had a little bit of
trust a little bit of faith in
themselves I get them to believe in
themselves I don't want them to be even
me yeah why don't to leave in themselves
okay if they have to believe in me first
great but believe in yourself I will
help you just the way you do helping
people all along the way it makes our
life richer is or is it because people
always ask why do you do this why do you
do this because like when you've got a
certain amount of money it's been proven
that that much more money doesn't make
you any more happier yeah it but but
what it does is is helping other people
and that's something I learned from Tony
you know the give is one of the six kind
of related factors and and he was said
to me we're gonna help other people help
other people I'm like I need to help
myself first you know it took me a while
to understand that yeah and that's why I
like you so much because you're got a
great brain you're very successful but
also you've got a big heart and we like
to give back so thanks so much cooler on
the show it's been really great - good
to see you thanks thanks so get down
link below subscribe to his webinar and
also if you've not already subscribed to
this channel do that too and I look
forward to seeing you next time god
bless
thank you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time